my Rosso design are very simple just
listen closely
research extensively and innovate as
best as I can the power of the line is
in its ability to connect create and
relate when an architect designs a
building it all begins with lines on
paper they come together to create a
full visual narrative of the built
environment we call it the blueprint
when put into construction these lines
enable our complex building environment
to be formed and these lines are the
ones that create the spaces and the
places where people will move interact
and relate the role of an architect
indeed multifaceted we need to be good
listeners to understand the needs of the
owners the stakeholders the communities
and end-users we also need to be
persuasive to cooks the best solutions
from our engineers and consultants and
in the midst of all these we need to be
creative to put all the ideas together
to derive the best design solution the
architect has the power to translate a
planners vision and realize a developer
screen and give life to a community's
hope and as architects we should be
aware of the great responsibilities that
we hold I would encourage young
designers to have the courage to pursue
their own individual ideas for all
designers architects in our own rice we
have wonderful ideas of our own and I
think that if we are always confident
and bold enough to showcase that part of
ourselves we will be so much better
right
[Music]